[Musique]
le 1er septembre dernier c'était la
reprise pour 91 mille collégiens haut
rhinois et le grand déménagement pour
les jeunes du collège kennedy
en effet l'établissement situé en centre
ville étant en travaux jusqu'en décembre
professeurs et élèves se sont installés
dans les locaux de l'ancien lycée
camille claudel
on a très vite compris que c'était
difficile en site occupé de pouvoir
envisager les travaux et donc nous
sommes arrivés à la solution de
déménager de transférer les élèves vers
un autre site et donc en l'occurrence
heures cet ancien lycée claudel à côté
du collège villon pour pouvoir
travailler de façon d'abord sur le
chantier de façon dans de meilleures
conditions et de pouvoir ici au à
l'ancien lycée claudel accueillir dans
de bonnes conditions les élèves sans
être perturbé par le chantier la rentrée
des élèves s'est passé dans de bonnes
conditions
la ville de mulhouse l'agglomération le
département et l'éducation nationale ont
travaillé main dans la main pour que
cette rentrée un peu compliqué puisse se
dérouler sans accroc autre nouveauté de
la rentrée le port du masque pour tous
les élèves de plus de 11 ans conséquence
de la crise sanitaire dans les collèges
haut rhinois le conseil départemental a
décidé d'agir pour que les élèves
puissent suivre les cours en toute
sécurité
nous avons décidé si besoin en était de
renforcer nos équipes avec des
prestataires extérieurs pour le
nettoyage à des infections des locaux
etc
ensuite nous avons prévu d'apporter aux
établissements qui le souhaitent ou qui
on manquerait du gel hydroalcoolique
supplémentaire ils peuvent nous
demandé et puis on a décidé de mettre un
stock de masques à disposition de chaque
établissement
pour permettre aux familles qui seraient
financièrement un peu un peu justes ou
ou démunies de pouvoir obtenir un masque
qui seraient fournis par la collectivité
ainsi que ceux qui auraient oublié ou
les petits accidents le mas qui casse
etc qui se déchire donc les
établissements peuvent faire face à ces
petits problèmes
le coronavirus est dans toutes les têtes
en ce mois de septembre le conseil
départemental n'oublie pas ses
engagements pour la réussite scolaire
des élèves
l'institution a prévu de dépenser 500
millions d'euros pour les collèges sur
la période 2010 8 2028
ça concerne à la fois le fonctionnement
de chaque collège public mais aussi
privé et donc est également les
investissements indispensables pour
restructurer les établissements qui en
ont besoin on a fait un inventaire et on
a répertorié les différents
établissements au travers d'un livre
blanc qui sont qui doivent être
restructurées voir reconstruit on va
également construire deux nouveaux
collèges en plus des reconstructions des
collèges actuelle et ses deux nouveaux
collèges se situeront à kembs là pour
2020 24 25 et un autre collège un
nouveau collège à mulhouse pour l'année
suivante au titre des investissements
dans le bâti les travaux du collège
kennedy à mulhouse pour un coût de 15
millions d'euros
autre volet important les
investissements dans le numérique déjà
incontournable le confinement et la
nécessité de l'enseignement à distance
leur ont rendu indispensable
ainsi pour cette année l'enveloppé
allouée par le département représente
2,1 millions d'euros nous voulons
naturellement développé ce numérique est
très important dans notre société à
l'heure actuelle et on a vu encore au
niveau 2 de la pandémie et donc nous
avons accéléré les choses au niveau des
collèges avec non seulement des appels à
projets non seulement des nouvelles de
nouveaux ordinateurs nous avons quand
même changé à peu près plus de cent
mille ordinateurs les projecteurs là
aussi nous avons changé pratiquement
tous les projecteurs et nous avons aussi
des appels à projets est pour l'instant
plus de la moitié de nos collèges 57
collèges sont pourvus de tablettes scène
expérimentale
et nous allons essayer de développer ça
pour les élèves mais aussi de doter les
professeurs de deux tablettes pour
qu'ils puissent vraiment mener à bien
tous ses projets numériques
le département du haut-rhin investit
également dans la promotion du
bilinguisme un budget d'1 7 million
d'euros est allouée à cette action
différents projets sont en cours mais
l'un des plus prometteurs est le
recrutement d'intervenants bilingue dans
les écoles une expérience est en cours
en vue d'un déploiement plus large que
la collectivité européenne d'alsace sera
en place les deux départements décidé de
créer et de faire une action pour
soutenir et aider toutes les opérations
bide de bilinguisme dans nos collèges
alors il s'agit pas de remplacer les
professeurs de qui oeuvre au niveau de
l'éducation nationale mais pas du tout
mais au contraire c'est une affaire
complémentaires pour essayer de soutenir
tout ce qui se fait en engageant un
certain nombre de nos pros de
professeurs spécialistes dans le
problème dans deux bilingues et
naturellement l'allemand enfin le 1er
janvier prochain le conseil
départemental du haut-rhin fusionnera
avec son voisin bas rhinois pour créer
la collectivité européenne d'alsace au
niveau de l'exécutif départemental
on tient à rassurer les budgets les
actions et le calendrier décidé par
l'institution seront maintenus par la
future collectivité
le collège est un axe essentiel
principal c'est une compétence
régalienne que nous exercerons le
département du bas rhin a également mis
en oeuvre un programme similaire à celui
du haut rhin
les deux programmes départementaux de
rénovation et de remise à niveau des
collèges vont converger à partir de 1er
janvier sous l'égide la sela et la scea
s'attachera à poursuivre cette politique
d'investissements et de modernisation de
nos collèges